good morning everybody you're very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News again live from dining
Street this morning seven o'clock an
apology from the Prime Minister her mini
budget in shreds and a number of her own
MPS calling for her to go or they'll do
it themselves one even giving her only
one to two weeks to survive will she
joining us shortly from the government
the Armed Forces Minister James happy
plus the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves
it's Tuesday the 18th of October
I'm sorry an apology from the Prime
Minister as she prepares to face her
cabinet this morning but she's uh saying
she's going nowhere for now
I recognize we have made mistakes I'm
sorry for those mistakes
but I fixed mistakes
and a weekday winter blackout warning
comes as the chancellor announced that
the energy bill support will now end in
April I'll be getting reaction from a
small business here in Romford
see you in court the TUC General
Secretary warns the government over
strikes and has a cost of living warning
will speak to her at 7 45.
gone into the Top Guns how China is
recruiting former British military
Pilots to train their own on huge
salaries
prisoners swap a deal between Ukraine
and Russia follows yesterday's drone
attacks on Kiev
frightened and Confused a tearful Kevin
Spacey tells a court he was shocked by
accusations he made an unwanted sexual
advance on a teenager
and analyze this what the PM and her
Chancellor's body language might tell us
about what they think about each other
we're joined by a body language expert
just after nine
foreign
everybody the Prime Minister will face
her cabinet this morning after her late
night apology for the recent economic
turmoil following her mini budget Liz
truss says she's sorry but that she's
not going anywhere for now or of her own
choosing at least her new Chancellor
spent yesterday shredding the rest of
her mini budget as the PM spent the
night trying to shore up support behind
her
five conservative MPS have now publicly
called for the PM to consider her
position they are Crispin blunt Jamie
Wallace and Andrew bridgen Angela
Richardson and Charles Walker Mr Walker
told us if the PM doesn't resign she'll
be forced out in the next one to two
weeks our political correspondent Liz
Bates reports
hold up in number 10 and Holding On by a
thread the Prime Minister last night
reached out to her cabinet inviting them
around for drinks and then to the nation
asking for forgiveness I recognize we
have made mistakes
I'm sorry for those mistakes
but I fixed the mistakes I've appointed
a new Chancellor we have restored
economic stability and fiscal discipline
and what I now want to do is go on and
deliver for the public the PM is
detained on urgent business it will take
more than white wine and warm words to
erase the memory of another humiliating
day which began when she was a no-show
in the House of Commons where is the
prime minister
mistress did finally emerge but it was
her new Chancellor that took charge Mr
Speaker this government will take the
difficult demolishing what was left of
her doomed mini budget she sat silent
sidelined speaking out though the
growing chorus of critics if she doesn't
go right now it will not be her decision
that agency will be taken away from her
even some of her supporters are now
asking without her policies what is the
point of her Premiership
some agree she has to go now to limit
the damage what they can't agree on yet
is how to remove her and who should
replace her looking more like a wartime
president than a loyal Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt seemed to be suggesting himself
yesterday
as he took Center Stage but he denied
wanting the top job I rule it out Mrs
hunt rules it out three hunt children
rule it out others were adamant Liz
truss will enjoy this period do you feel
personally sorry for her no not at all I
mean the Prime Minister has a cabinet
around her she's been foreign secretary
she's had already had experience of some
of the challenges of the great officers
of State let's just does she have your
backing 100 is she the person to lead
you to the next general election well
people often accuse politicians of not
giving a straight answer so I'll just
simply say yes and yes
today the Prime Minister plans to get
back to work meeting her cabinet and
more conservative MPS trying to show
that it's business as usual behind the
scenes though it's still anything but
Liz Bates Sky News Westminster
joining us now is the Armed Forces
Minister James heapey from just across
the road Ministry of Defense Mr hippie
good morning to you thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
what's the point of Liz truss as prime
minister and I
Liz is the elected leader of our party
and the Prime Minister United Kingdom
she's hard at work in the building
behind you delivering for our nation
she's referred to uh jokingly by people
uh including George Osborne as Pino
prime minister in name only
that's not a name that I recognize so
she's been very uh candid about the
mistake that was made and she's
apologized for that and I think that
that counts for a lot there's leadership
in doing that but I think people forget
that there is more to being prime
minister than what you see on camera and
right now we are in a world where some
really big decisions have to be made the
global economy is moving in a direction
where all major economies around the
world are needing to react and those are
big decisions for the prime minister to
take with her Chancellor but so too are
their real security concerns uh right
now which requires some really big
decisions uh with her fellow world
leaders and I can see a prime minister
who is at hard at work on doing those
things and I grateful that she was quick
in making the change and crucially in
apologizing the British people for the
mistake that was made but she is very
much our prime minister and for what
it's worth I think that she is doing a
good job
she didn't choose to
this U-turn it was forced upon her
wasn't it
oh absolutely okay and there is and I
don't think anybody disputes that it was
forced upon her for two reasons firstly
by her own admission she and the
previous Chancellor chose to go too far
and too fast uh with a package of
measures that would have
potentially brought growth quicker to
the UK economy but were out of kilter
with where the markets were at that
moment and then add to that that there
is a big International movement going on
in the global economy right now I think
the IMF overnight have pointed to the
fact that
um other major European economies are
likely to go into recession Bloomberg I
think have said that it's very likely
that the us is going to go into
recession so when you when you put those
two things together a mistake in that
she sought to go too far too fast within
the setting of a global economic
situation of course this was forced upon
her and it took an enormous amount of
courage and Leadership to recognize that
make the change quickly apologize to the
British people which I think you would
reflect I hope is a contrast to a year
ago when the previous Prime Ministers
woes began she has fronted up to her
mistake very quickly
um and you know there are people in the
Parliamentary party who don't want that
to be an end of it but I think for an
awful lot of us we recognize that this
is a moment when the country needs its
government to knuckle down and get back
on with the day job
with all due respect Mr heapi she's
changed her mind because the markets
were tanking if the bank of England
hadn't stepped in the pensioners would
not have had their Pension funds
protected by the bank of England she had
no other choice than to do a vault fast
did you support when you heard the mini
Budget on the 23rd of September did you
think that's a good idea or did you
think what on Earth are they playing at
no I Look to be completely honest with
UK when the mini budget was presented to
us in the cabinet meeting uh immediately
for the before the Chancellor's
statement each and every one of those
measures was consistent with the
approach to growth that the government
was seeking and we all in gov in cabinet
accepts Collective responsibility for
the fact that that mini budget was given
and it is important for all of us to be
very honest about that it's not just the
Prime Minister who made that mistake
although she has owned it and apologized
for it
are you sorry yes 100 I I just you know
the the reality is that that scale of
intervention
based on borrowing
at a moment when the guilts market was
as vulnerable as it is because of these
ldi mechanisms that have become so
pervasive uh within Pension funds
is not sustainable it was a it was a
mistake and the intervention that was
required from the bank of England
thereafter was very necessary but so too
has been the government's decision to
roll back on many of those measures
although it's important to note that the
national and insurance cut the stamp
Duty cut and crucially the intervention
on energy bills still stands but beyond
that the government has rode back
because it recognizes that the markets
are important the rate at which the
government borrows is absolutely
essential to the stability of our
economy and our spending plans going
forward and the Prime Minister has
addressed that
okay so the whole cabinet all supported
this mini budget before it was put to
the House of Commons is that what you
just said yes
okay so none of you knew what you were
doing so why on Earth are you still
running the country
well okay I'm not sure that I think that
that is fair comments I think that the
uh the budget was presented to cabinet
and each and every one of the measures
within it were in and off themselves
coherent with a plan to drive growth but
if you're asking why I think I as a
defense minister deserve to continue to
sit around the cabinet table I would
reflect that we here in the ministry of
Defense are doing a good job of keeping
our nation safe at a time of incredible
Global insecurity my boss Ben Wallace is
in Washington this morning uh having the
sort of conversations that
beyond belief really the fact that we're
at a time when these sort of
conversations are necessary
um I think that in this department we've
done a good job and we've got a good
record on which to stand and actually I
could say the same for every other
colleague around governments in their
Department too
to keep our country safe we need to keep
our economy safe and we saw immediately
that the markets thought you'd all lost
your minds
well I I think we're in violence
agreements I've been very honest with
you throughout this interview as the
Prime Minister was in her interview last
night that the reaction of the markets
caused a change in plan that was a plan
that was changed quickly and the prime
minister's owned and apologized for
but the fact is that the markets have
since been reassured and that is also a
good thing and a reflection of her
leadership and the fact that she now has
a Chancellor in number 11 in whom the
city has confidence and that is that is
a good thing
how many more mistakes can she afford to
make
well I suspect given how uh skittish our
politics are at the moment not very many
but she wouldn't have wanted to have
made the mistake that she's made
to her credit she has owned it and
apologized for it but my experience of
the Prime Minister when she was foreign
secretary and Secretary of State for
international trade and the the
international facing departments work
quite closely as we deliver our nation's
foreign policy is that the Prime
Minister makes good decisions based on
the evidence she listens to her
officials and throughout her time as
Secretary of State for international
trade and foreign secretary I think a
record shows that there is no hiding
from the fact that a mistake was made
around the mini budget but it's one that
she has owned and apologized for and now
crucially the country needs its
governments to get on with the task at
hand because there is an awful lot in
the entry
how many more mistakes can she make for
you
well I I just so many hey I just said I
I don't think that there's the
opportunity to make any more mistakes
because the nation needs a government
that is governing well and is making
good decisions the nation also needs a
government that is honest where mistakes
are made
okay and if she does make any more
mistakes from what you're saying she's
toast
um it does look as though potentially
your department may have to suffer Cuts
uh we're hearing that potentially 15
percent across the board is what the uh
foreign
secretary now uh Chancellor de facto
prime minister some people are calling
him if there are cuts to your department
that mean that we don't see the two and
a half percent of GDP spent on defense
three percent by 2028 what does that
mean for you
well there's there's a number of things
that you said there that weren't quite
right if you'll allow so the commitment
that the Prime Minister made is three
percent by 2030. uh and to be clear
um like the Secretary of State
um that is something that I believe must
be delivered given the need to keep our
nation safe in increasingly uncertain
times you cannot have Prosperity at home
or internationally without security and
that is a really good reason to be
investing in defense now if in the very
immediate term there is a requirement to
look at what we can do to help the
treasury out that's a discussion for the
chancellor to have with the secretary of
state but I am confident that the Prime
Minister and the chancellor and the
foreign secretary and frankly everyone
else around government understands the
importance of investing in our nation's
armed forces and our defenses at a time
when the UK interest at home and abroad
is under such threat
okay so if I said to you if there were
Cuts in the ministry defense budget in
the short term would that impact on our
support for Ukraine I know what you
would say you would say no so I would
then have to put it to you if I may Mr
hippie that would mean Brits uh
elsewhere around the world would find
themselves in a difficult position
well okay I think that that is true
there is there are some very hard
choices to make and we have to be very
clear on why we are doing what we're
doing in Ukraine why it's so important
to be supporting the Ukrainian Armed
Forces why it's so important to be
investing in our own Defense Forces at
the moment and that's because the cost
of not doing those things is that we
will be living in a Europe in a world
whereby it has been shown that if you
are willing to be belligerent and use
Force to threaten the sovereignty of
another country you can succeed that the
International Community loses patience
that it blinks and it gives in and you
get your way and what that does is set
us on a trajectory for the rest of this
Century whereby we will be having to
spend a lot more on our defense and
security and where our economy will be
profoundly impacted by that insecurity
so this is this is about investing now
in the ukrainians so that they can do do
the right thing in order to draw a line
underneath Putin's aggression to show
that a rules-based International System
still applies in this century
and I think that all of your viewers
would agree that is the right thing to
be doing because the alternative is a
world that is more unstable more
insecure and a whole lot less prosperous
Mr hippie Authority if you would please
sir about our Top Guns um heading off to
China to train potentially future
enemies how to fly planes
yeah and it's been a concern within the
mod for a number of years uh
counter-intelligence people have been
looking at it closely uh we are we have
approached the people that are involved
uh and been clear with them that it is
our expectation that they would not
continue to be part of that organization
and we are going to put into law that
once people have been given that warning
it would become an offense to then go uh
forward and continue with that training
um China is a competitor that
um is threatening the UK interest uh in
many places around the world it's also
an important trading partner but there
is no secret in their attempt to gain
access to our secrets and the
recruitment of our pilots in order to
understand the capabilities of our air
force is clearly a concern to us and the
intelligence uh part of the mod
okay so don't be a tray to come home
before you can't and we put you in jail
what
yeah don't go and train foreign Air
Forces without checking with the mod
whether they're a foreign Air Force that
we want to see you train would be a
pretty good rule
okay good to see you Mr hoopy thank you
very much indeed for joining us you too
okay thank you thank you Tamara's here
thoughts tomorrow good morning morning
Kate well a member of her cabinet saying
how many more mistakes can Liz truss
afford to make not very many uh probably
none after an extraordinary day and I
know we use that word a lot but really
watching the Prime Minister sit next to
her brand new Chancellor as he ripped up
every bit of the economic plan on which
she was elected which her former
Chancellor presented only three weeks
ago rip up all of the key measures
leaving just a couple of measures which
have already been legislated for and say
we are not doing this anymore because we
need to get the market we need to get
the economy back on track and this is
the only way to do it oh and by the way
when we said there'd be no spending cuts
there are actually going to be loads
watching Liz trust to sit there not
saying a thing and just have to watch
everything on which she was elected
ripped up was quite something to behold
with labor MPS baiting her for not
saying anything and members of her own
party publicly and behind the scenes
saying how long has she got now the
Prime Minister herself gave an interview
last night saying for first time since
this term will unfolded that she's sorry
that she got it not not just that she's
had to tweak her plan that she's sorry
and then she said she still planned to
lead the conservatives into the next
election and watching that you wonder if
she was even convinced when she was
saying it because um just to give you a
flavor of how this is going down I mean
these are these are sort of newspapers
that are normally supportive of the
Prime Minister we've got the son the
ghost PM we've got the Daily Mail in
office but not in power I mean for a
prime minister who's been in office
barely a month this is not the
atmosphere that you that can really last
very long
um there are also sort of write-ups of
what these changes will mean for
people's finances at home before we even
get on to sort of spending cuts you know
what it's going to mean for mortgages
what it's going to mean for energy bills
because one of the big announcements
yesterday was support with energy bills
is only going to be for six months so
having come to power promising tax cuts
we're now looking at potentially tax
Rises and a lot of painful spending cuts
and how long that can that situation
last is what conservative MPS are asking
them yeah the other thing that struck me
uh from Mr hippie this morning the Armed
Forces Minister a about obviously about
the Top Guns come on before you can't
but also Collective responsibility the
cabinet did know he says about the mini
budget before it was put to Parliament
and they all agreed on it absolutely and
he you know yes there was some measures
they didn't know about like the 45p rate
but the general thrust was and he was
one of her early supporters he and a
couple of other ministers of rising star
ministers backed Liz truss did they not
think you can't have masses of tax cuts
and not have any means of paying for
them as her rival Rishi sunak pointed
out in every single one of their
encounters and he says well each each
individual measure was defensible
perhaps the whole package wasn't and who
has to take the flight for that
eventually the person at the top and Liz
truss is now battling very hard for
survival I think the next a couple of
days are going to be crucial because
conservatives who want to to get rid of
her want think that she can't lead them
into the next election don't quite have
a plan don't have a candidate to Rally
around they'll need to see whether they
can coalesce around an alternative yeah
I think the headline from that interview
for me was no more mistakes or you're
out yeah prime minister thanks very much
tomorrow with me throughout the morning
here on Downing Street still to come on
the program this hour speaking to the
former Chief secretary to the treasury
about the New Economic Policy revealed
Yesterday by the chancellor the UK is on
course with two decades of lost living
standards so I'll be speaking to the TUC
General Secretary Francisco Grady she
says Britain needs a proper pay rise
and next hour joined by Rachel Reid
Shadow Chancellor of the exchequer
China has recruited former British
military Pilots to teach its Armed
Forces how to defeat Western warplanes
and helicopters on huge salaries the
Armed Forces Minister James teepe just
told us it's a concern our secretary our
security rather and defense editor
that's Deborah Haynes of course reports
for us
China has a lot to learn to compete with
the us as the world's top gun
but some former British military Pilots
appear willing to offer advice in return
for generous pay packages
a western official says around 30 x fast
jet and helicopter Pilots are working in
China right now and more are being
targeted in what one analyst called a
major security breach let's be honest
China is an enemy
um as such we have got a British
subjects who have decided that their
interests are best served by teaching
our enemy how to defeat us this is
incredibly frightening
pilots who can fly Jets like this
typhoon as well as others curiously
haven't broken any laws by training the
Chinese it's an embarrassing loophole
that's quickly being closed including
with new legislation
a Ministry of Defense spokesperson said
all serving and former Personnel are
already subject to the official Secrets
Act
and we are reviewing the use of
confidentiality contracts and
non-disclosure agreements across defense
while the new National Security bill
will create additional tools to tackle
contemporary security challenges
including this one
recruiters have also targeted pilots who
fly the UK's F-35 fast Jets
it has top secret technology a prime
target for Espionage
but officials say they don't believe any
F-35 Personnel accepted the lure of
salaries of around 240 000 pounds
the mod has issued an alert warning
serving and former staff to be aware of
these approaches and turn them down
Deborah Haynes skynees
um just uh want to update you on what's
happening in Ukraine this morning uh by
the Royce's news agency Ukrainian
presidential aide saying there have been
three strikes that have hit an energy
object in Kiev guessing that must be
some sort of Power Station uh that
according to the Reuters news agents
quoting a presidential Aid that three
strikes have hit an energy object in uh
Kiev we're being told to take more
prisoners is the message from president
zielinski's message to the Ukrainian
troops saying it would make it easier to
secure the release of soldiers being
held by Russia
foreign
that coming after one of the biggest
prisoner exchanges since the Russian
invasion yesterday which saw 108
Ukrainian female prisoners of War return
to their country over a hundred Russians
were also freed in The Exchange
and it's a week today since Russia
launched major missile attacks on
Ukraine yesterday ukrainians rushed to
shelters again as Russia used reportedly
iranian-made explosive Laden drones on
the capital city Kiev the White House
has condemned the latest attacks and
says it will enforce the sanctions on
both Russia and Iran president zielinski
said the latest attacks were further
proof of the need to strengthen his
country's air defenses
just now there is a new Russian drone
attack drones are being shot down the
world can and must stop this Terror when
we talk about Ukraine's need for air and
missile defense we are talking about
real lives that are being taken by
terrorists terrorists
we managed to shoot down some of the
missiles and drones in just 12 hours
from 9pm Sunday 37 Iranian short heads
and several cruise missiles were
destroyed
people have died after a Russian fighter
jet crashed into a residential building
in the southern city of yes shortly
after taking off on Monday yet Glides on
the sea of azov opposite the Russian
occupied city of mariopol in southern
Ukraine
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and Kevin Spacey
has denied allegations of sexual assault
but his Civil Trial in New York the
American actor who was tearful told a
court in the U.S he was shocked and
confused by accusations he made an
unwanted sexual advance on a teenager in
the 80s the actor and singer Anthony
Rapp claims that he was 14 when the
actors sexually assaulted him at a party
in his Manhattan apartment
the family of a man who died after being
tasered by officers and jumping into the
Thames have threatened legal action
against a police Watchdog relatives of
41 year old
um oladage amishaw want a judicial
review of the decision not to hold a
criminal or misconduct investigation
into his death
in Nigeria devastating floods have
killed more than 600 people and
displaced 1.3 million people this year
across 33 of the countries 36 States
authorities have struggled to evacuate
residents in affected areas at least 340
000 hectares of Farmland has also been
submerged increasing fears of food
supply disruptions
a Sri Lankan author has won the booker
prize for his novel The Seven moons of
Mali Almeida he was presented the award
by the queen consort in his victory
speech he said he hopes that in years to
come seven moons will be in the fantasy
section of the Bookshop
still to come on the program the Prime
Minister has apologized for mistakes
made during her first five weeks as
leader speaking to the conservative MP
David gork amid growing calls for the PM
to reconsider her position that to come
foreign
everybody welcome back to the breakfast
show here on Sky News we're outside
number 10 we are awaiting a cabinet
meeting this morning we'll see lots of
the prime minister's cabinet arriving um
in the next hour I would anticipate that
meeting at 8 45 this morning
um all of that cabinet were told by the
Armed Forces Minister took Collective
responsibility for the mini budget which
has now been completely trashed by the
new Chancellor we also heard from the
Armed Forces Minister who told us that
the Prime Minister cannot afford to make
any more mistakes joining us now the
former Financial secretary to the
treasury that's David Court Mr Gort good
morning to you James TV saying no more
mistakes or she's toast what do you
think
or he clearly in a very vulnerable
position and one only has to look at the
opinion polls and certainly conservative
MPS are currently looking at those
opinion polls
um to know that the government has got
huge problems and it will be difficult
for Liz trust to lead the conservative
party into the next general election I
think the the sense I get from my former
colleagues is that they they think they
need to change the leader but the
process could be very difficult there
isn't a consensus on who should replace
her and whilst That Remains the case she
will continue as as as pm
um will the Halloween budget be a
nightmare on dining Street
I think it's going to be very very
difficult so Jeremy Hunt was right to
take the steps that he did yesterday and
that's clearly provided some reassurance
to the markets
but I don't think we should
underestimate the size of the challenge
that he faces in terms of putting the
public finances on a sustainable footing
you know we've still had some unfunded
tax cuts in terms of the reversal of the
increase in National Insurance
contributions the general economy has
deteriorated in partly because of partly
because of international conditions uh
partly perhaps because confidence has
diminished and we're certainly paying
more in debt interest than we were and
that in part is a response to the mini
budget so the public finances are a
pretty difficult State and he's going to
have to find some more money from
somewhere you know possibly in the
region of 30 billion pounds or so that
is a lot of money to find and I think
it's going to be have to be a
combination of tax increases and
spending cuts and spending cuts will be
very painful in in these circumstances
so taxes I suspect will have to do quite
a lot of the heavy lifting and to raise
the sort of sums we're talking about I
think he's probably going to have to
look at some of those main taxes some of
those big Revenue raises income tax
National Insurance contributions or vat
and I'm not sure that um that's yet
taken on board by conservative MPS and
the public so I think that may come as a
bit of a surprise for people on the 31st
of October
how can the Prime Minister stay in
office
um when she said that she was going to
cut taxes borrow money to cut taxes and
from what you're saying the only way
that they can balance the books is to
actually increase things like income tax
enormously difficult I mean let's yeah
let's not uh ignore this man it's it's
pretty
humiliating for a prime minister to
campaign for the leadership on the basis
of lowering taxes and now to find that
she's unable to do so because the
markets worry about the sustainability
of the public finances and then to find
herself in the position I think which is
what she's going to be in of having to
put up taxes
um to try to rebuild that confidence and
that's a very very difficult position
for the prime minister so so I I agree
with the premise of your question I
think the challenge for the conservative
party is are they prepared to face up to
the fiscal realities and support Jeremy
Hunt when he announces tax increases if
indeed he does do that and then secondly
what do they do about the leadership and
and can they
reach a consensus on a candidate that
has credibility with the markets and is
able to lead the country through a very
difficult period
um when I interviewed Liz truss in
August she told me that there was enough
money in the rainy day fund something
like 30 billion pounds do you not agree
I don't I'm afraid that's gone
um you know the thing with the public
finances is that they can move around an
awful lot depending upon
International conditions for example and
and so what does have to be cautious and
you can't go around just spending the
Rainy Day part of the assumption that
it'll always be there so as I say the
fact that the economy is is likely to
have a bumpier period over the months
ahead means that that money disappears
we're also paying more in debt interest
partly because of the loss of confidence
um and and some of it's been spent on on
tax cuts so I'm afraid that that buffer
that was there has almost certainly
disappeared we'll know more when the ABR
presents its figures but yeah that was
one of the reasons why it was very
foolish to announce tax cuts when you
didn't have the abr's numbers showing
the up-to-date position in the public
finances
um we do think that um Jeremy Hunt would
make a good prime minister
if I say so it won't do him any favors
but I think um he's made a very good
start as Chancellor I think he has
reassured the markets I think he's been
able to communicate a sensible and
pragmatic response uh to all of this in
a way that the government wasn't
previously doing so I do think that um
you know he would have uh may he would
make a a a a competent and reliable uh
prime minister in these circumstances I
think there are others who would do the
same but I suspect that he's very he
genuinely is focused on his job as
childhood of the executive
um do you believe in when he says he
doesn't want to be prime minister
not a hundred percent
um
he's obviously had Ambitions in the past
um but uh I mean the sense I get from
him is that you know this is a perhaps a
a surprise last big job in government
that he pretty well thought that his um
uh Top Flight ministerial career was
over and he recognizes that he has come
to office in enormously challenging
circumstances and that largely his
political Legacy will be measured on how
he responds to those challenges and and
I think that's the right approach yeah
we do need a chancellor who is you know
who is focused on on on the task in
front of him
um and to be fair to Jeremy I think he's
sharing every indication of that he may
well not be terribly popular with
conservative MPS after the 31st of all
the 31st of October because yeah at that
point he is going to make some tough
decisions I think and and uh you know
what what is good for the markets might
not be good for his popularity with um
parliamentary colleagues uh never
underestimate the quiet guy is what I've
learned in my job it's good to talk to
you as always Mr Gort thanks very much
indeed a great thought tomorrow that was
that was Wendy Morton the chief whip um
she will be obviously she meets with the
Prime Minister very regularly so there's
nothing particularly significant about
that but if the prime minister is going
to be asking her how things are looking
in the Parliamentary party it is not
good news I mean the message from
conservatives is that Liz truss is
Clinging On by her fingertips and she
has to turn things around and it's very
very hard to see how she does this
morning we've seen normally friendly
newspapers turning on the Prime Minister
and saying that conservatives have to
decide whether they're going to replace
her with somebody else and she faces
kirst armor at Prime Minister's
questions tomorrow and when he says to
her your whole strategy has been
shredded what's the point of view I
think many the conservative party are
not sure what she will say to that they
have some big decisions to make okay
let's bring in should we the cabinet
office former Chief Economist
um Jonathan Porters um hi it's good to
see you this morning uh what did you
make of Jeremy Hunt's statement
yesterday Mr Portis
um well as you've all been saying um
obviously the trust experiment in uh um
rate what I would describe as
Reaganomics large unfunded tax cuts in
the hope of future growth has been
ditched largely for a version of um uh
what I would call austerity Mark II
um that is to say uh a return to
um and of course you know on this list
trust did have a point as again many of
your the people you've been talking to
have been saying she was right that the
last 12 years have hardly been a great
economic success we've had low growth
stagnant productivity historically very
good low growth and real wages so we are
what Jeremy Hunt announced was
essentially a return to that where we
will have some uh um we won't have much
in the way of tax cuts but what we will
have quite significant spending cuts and
as David said it's difficult to see how
these are either
economically socially or politically
sensible at the moment
interesting also Mr gork saying that he
thought that might have to see an income
tax rise are you in that school of
thought as well
um I think that's well I I mean I would
guess that's politically unlikely but
I'm not an expert on the politics what I
would say though
um I think David Cook is Right taxes do
in general need to go up if we want to
finance decent quality Public Services
if we want to reverse the rise in
poverty and destitution
um that we've seen over the last few
years we are going to need somewhat
higher taxes at least over the medium to
the long term
um and given the the nature of
inequality and poverty in that country
that means people like me and you are
going to have to pay more I personally
um I think that's the right thing to do
um I don't as it happens things that
just putting up income tax is
necessarily the right way to do it our
tax system is a mess it's quite
inefficient it is and again this for us
did get this right it is anti-growth in
some respects we need quite a radical
restructuring of our tax system that
increases taxes on wealth on property
and on people in the right at the the
upper end of the income and wealth
Distribution on people who are
relatively old and and who are not poor
who have done well out of the last 20 or
30 years
um that is going to be really quite
tough It's a long-term Vision but if we
want decent quality public services and
we want to keep on
stop us continuing to slip back as an
economy that's what's required
I wonder if a conservative government
would do that though given what their
fan base is if you will
uh it is I mean it to be fair it's very
difficult politically for any party yeah
people vote um you know and you have to
say we're not just going to tax
um Amazon and multi-million pound hedge
fund owners to the Tory party those
people should be taxed considerably more
in my view but that in itself isn't
enough you actually have to tax people
like me and you people who are doing
quite well thank you
um but are not in the the the league of
the super rich and of course those
people vote not all of them vote lots of
them about Tory but not all of them
Vector so it is I think very difficult
for any party to do that sort of radical
reform but the alternative is is a
continued degradation in our Public
Services continued uh series of crises
in the NHS as it struggles to cope with
steadily older population and I don't
think that's very attractive either and
moreover it's not it's not just bad from
a social point of view it's also bad
economically it's a part of the problem
we're having at the moment is that the
the the the the the understaffing in the
NHS is leading to knock on economic
problems as people are not going back to
work
um we have a higher rate of inactivity a
lower number of people in the workforce
precisely because the NHS is not coping
with the pressures it's currently under
you can't deal with that without having
somewhat higher levels of Taxation
okay good to talk to you thanks so much
indeed for your expertise much
appreciated thank you
um chatting thank you chatting to James
heapey um earlier this hour he says the
Prime Minister has got no more chances
if she makes another mistake she's out
well I suspect given how skittish our
politics are at the moment not very many
but she wouldn't have wanted to have
made the mistake that she's made to her
credit she has owned it and apologized
for it but my experience of the Prime
Minister when she was foreign secretary
and Secretary of State for international
trade and the the international facing
departments work quite closely as we
deliver our nation's foreign policy is
that the Prime Minister makes good
decisions based on the evidence she
listens to her officials and throughout
her time as Secretary of State for
international trade and foreign
secretary I think her record shows that
there is no hiding from the fact that a
mistake was made around the mini budget
but it's one that she has owned and
apologized for and now crucially the
country needs its governments to get on
with the task at hand because there is
an awful lot in the entry
how many more mistakes can she make for
you
well I I just so many hey I just said I
I don't think that there's the
opportunity to make any more mistakes
Chile this morning in dining Street
waiting for the cabinet to arrive
they'll no doubt be talking about the
news at a winter blackout warning
um has come from the boss of the
National Grid following the news the
government is now planning to end
support for energy bills in April rather
than keep it going for two years Jamal
has more good morning
good morning Kay yeah that's right so
John and Petty grow the head of the
National Grid has said that households
should be prepared for winter blackouts
between 4 P.M and 7 P.M in the evening
now he and the government have said that
this is extremely unlikely but it is a
possibility isn't it otherwise he
wouldn't have mentioned it and as you
say it comes as the chancellor announced
that this energy support package will
now end in April it was meant to last a
lot longer than that but the government
says it wasn't financially feasible to
do so so it now means it will end in
April and a part of that package was to
ensure that the uh the average unit cost
of energy will be limited to two and a
half thousand pounds per household so
that's two and a half thousand pounds
maximum that a household would have to
pay a typical household but as we know
two and a half thousand pounds an awful
lot of money for many people so come
April some households may have to find
money that they don't have to try and
top up for their energy bills
okay thanks so much indeed of course if
we do see blackouts that's going to
cause all sorts of problems for all of
us what impact might it have on the NHS
as well let's hear from Matthew Taylor
Chief exec of the NHS Confederation
we're waiting for this winter plan
aren't we for the NHS is that coming
today do you think
I think today uh or tomorrow and what
we're expecting is uh
a set of measures to deal with the
problem particularly of access access to
emergency departments the problem of
hospitals that are full because it's
difficult to get people out of Hospital
once they're in the hospital so I think
these will be measures that we'll try to
address that that issue of access
through measures like for example full
Services which enable support from
Community Services to people who've had
fools rather than those people
necessarily needing an ambulance or
being taken to emergency departments and
also support for people with respiratory
problems because of course in Winter you
see a growth in those respiratory
illnesses and again that'll be an
attempt to divert people from needing to
call ambulances and go to emergency
departments and and along with all of
that extra beds we simply need uh more
beds so this would be a set of measures
I think to help us cope with the winter
crisis what they won't be able to do is
address the fundamental of the Health
Service right now which is a gap between
the level of demand we're facing
unprecedented level of demand and the
capacity that we've got to meet that
demand
what about Staffing
well Staffing is a huge issue we have
130 000 vacancies in the Health Service
160 000 in Social care
it's interesting now that Jeremy Hunt is
the chance because of course he was
chair of the Health and Care select
committee and in that role he'd made
absolutely clear that something has got
to be done about the workforce crisis in
the NHS he'd called for a proper costed
Workforce plan and we hope very much
that as Chancellor he will stand by that
commitment
uh but would he ring fence uh the NHS
budget as Chancellor
I don't think the question really is
about about Ring fencing it's about
giving the Health and Care System the
resources that it needs in the face of a
situation which you know is absolutely
clear I don't think anybody would deny
the realities of the fact that the
health services finding it difficult to
cope even though for example GPS are
offering more appointments and before
covert even though we've managed to more
or less get rid of two-year waiters
other important bits of progress in
areas like Diagnostics but despite all
of that and the incredibly hard working
style staff who don't forget most of
whom had to struggle through the
Intensive years of of of covid so you
know that that's the kind of day-to-day
reality that we face in health so it's
the government allocated money to US
last Autumn already that money is worth
four billion pounds less because of
inflation it looks like it'll be worth
seven billion pounds less next year we
also have a 10 billion pound Capital
shortfall That's essential maintenance
essential infrastructure actual word so
the question for the Health Service is
how do we invest to close that capacity
out and to enable the Health Service to
reform and to modernize that's the
question
if there's any suggestion that the NHS
can can take Cuts without an immediate
and substantial impact on patient care
I'm afraid that's that's delusional it's
simply not possible to cut the Health
Service without those consequences
almost out of time do you think nurses
and doctors will go on strike
I very much hope that they don't we
understand
the feeling amongst staff because their
pay increases are lagging behind
inflation and we hope that we can find a
way of moving forward recognizing the
challenges the health service has with
recruiting and retaining staff right now
okay thank you Francis O'Grady is
joining us now uh the General Secretary
of the TUC the trades Union Congress
hello Mr O'Grady thank you for joining
us do you think doctors and nurses
should go on strike
I think what we're seeing is an
unprecedented squeeze on people's living
standards doctors and nurses and all the
healthcare staff and many other public
servants thousands of pounds worse off
in real terms compared to where they
were before the bankers crash so of
course people don't want to be in this
position and we'll see how they vote in
those ballots but I don't think the
government should underestimate the
absolute despair of public servants and
many working people that you know we're
seeing everybody at the top doing well
big shareholder dividends and public
servants expected to suck up another
real pay cut at a time they just can't
afford it families are at Breaking Point
should doctors and nurses go on strike
though
if they vote for it yes but nobody wants
to be in this position I mean I'm I'm
sure you've spoken to nurses I certainly
have and other Healthcare staff this is
their vocation they certainly don't want
to be in a position they want to have a
fair agreement and fair pay but of
course if there's no other alternative
if people are pushed to the limit and
we're seeing food banks opening in
hospitals for given's sake people are
pushed to the Limit then of course
they'll stand together and be very clear
to the government that working people
are just not prepared to pay the price
for the mess that they have caused and
it is one Almighty mess that they've
caused from that budget even now they're
rowing back but the damage has been done
what do you make of the proposals from
uh Liz truss the Prime Minister for
anti-strike laws that would protect
places like hospitals and also keep the
trains running
it's part of a package that the
government has been pursuing uh also
threatening to weaken workers rights
important rights like rights to holiday
pay time off for mums and dads rights
that came from Europe that the Prime
Minister and Jacob Reese smog the
business secretary are threatening to
weaken
but this is a distraction from the cost
of living crisis that they have caused
they want everybody to be talking about
taking away what we see as a fundamental
British Liberty instead of focusing on
the absolute chaos and crash they have
caused in our economy and to be frank
they have no mandate for deep posterity
Cuts Liz truss promised there'd be no
spending cuts her predecessors said
there'd be no spending cuts where is the
Mandate and authority and credibility
for this government to wield the acts on
our NHS and public services it does
doesn't have one what do you make of the
energy price guarantee being scrapped
after April of next year
well obviously the government intends to
review that presumably but being no
doubt that I think working families are
in facing huge uncertainty and worry in
the months ahead we know that even with
the help that's been announced energy
bills on average will double uh this
winter other prices are going up child
care food so of course Working Families
are really worried but I think
determined that when we see huge profits
being made huge bonanzas in the city on
Bankers bonuses that you know working
people have had enough they'll have to
look elsewhere to dig themselves out of
this hole
okay it's good to talk to you thanks so
much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning thank you we are
live in dining street again for you this
morning the reason we're here is because
it is cabinet today so all of those
people in cabinet who took Collective
responsibility for that mini budget
which was absolutely trashed Yesterday
by the new Chancellor we'll be sitting
around the table talking about what the
next moves are we heard from David Gorka
used to be a leading member of a
previous Tory government saying we could
potentially see uh income tax increases
in order to pay for that 30 billion
pound black hole that Liz trust still
has to deal with going forward we are
expecting uh the main Budget on the 31st
of October that from the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt he was asked yesterday
whether he fancied his chances as prime
minister he said that he doesn't want to
be prime minister Mrs hunt doesn't want
him to be prime minister all three of
the hunt children do don't want him to
be prime minister which means that he's
obviously not ruled it out well I don't
know we'll have to put that to him as
far as Liz truss is concerned she made a
late night interview available to us
where she was saying that she had made
mistakes and that she was sorry I was
speaking to the Armed Forces Minister
this morning James heapey and he was
saying he acknowledges that she's made a
mistake and that he accepts that but she
cannot make any more mistakes if she
wants to remain in the office of number
10. she is behind that door this morning
not literally I'm sure but perhaps she
is a waiting to greet her cabinet 8 45
is when we're expecting the cabinet
meeting or thereabouts we'll bring you
the very latest here on Sky News
breakfast show do stay tuned
[Music]